-Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs,
and we especially love songs
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
That's right.
It's time for "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Something song,
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Oh, yeah.
Welcome to "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Before the show, we went through
our great audience,
our lovely audience,
and we picked out two people
who said they were musicians.
We don't know if they are.
But we gave them each
a made-up song title
and gave them an hour
to write an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage minutes ago.
There you go.
I can't wait to see
what they came up with,
so let's meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
Welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you.
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
How are you?
-Good.
-Alright, here we go.
Contestant number 1,
what is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's Marcia Belsky,
and I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
-Yeah, Brooklyn!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on! Marcia Belsky.
Marcia, what was the title
that was given to you?
-It was "Scrolling Through
TikTok on Thanksgiving Day."
-Yeah, that's right.
I feel like a lot of people
will be doing that.
"Scrolling Through TikTok
on Thanksgiving Day."
What instrument
will you be playing?
-I'm doing piano.
-Oh, I love the piano.
Alright, good.
Alright, why don't you go over
and get ready,
get inspired, get set,
and get ready to hear...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere of
the soon-to-be classic
"Scrollin' TikTok
on Thanksgiving Day,"
it's Marcia Belsky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Last year this time, I was so
lonely at the holidays ♪
♪ But this year,
I'll be sitting right across
from everyone I love ♪
♪ As I scroll TikTok
on Thanksgiving Day ♪
♪ Scrollin' TikTok
♪ Watching couples
who hate each other
pull dangerous pranks like ♪
♪ Watch me scare
my pregnant wife, okay ♪
♪ Now your baby's on its way ♪
♪ Scrollin' TikTok
on Thanksgiving Day ♪
♪ A 12-year-old tarot reader
said love's coming my way ♪
♪ I'm in community here with
the tweens on TikTok, baby ♪
♪ Scrollin' TikTok
on Thanksgiving Day ♪
♪ I'm so thankful for my phone ♪
♪ And I guess also my family ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's great.
"And I guess also my family."
Marcia Belsky!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, that was incredible!
Come on over, Marcia.
Yeah, "I'm so thankful for
my phone.
Oh, yeah, and also my family."
Yeah. Alright, let's meet
contestant number 2.
What is your name?
And where are you from?
-My name is Brooks Allison.
I'm from Brooklyn, as well.
-Hey, Brooklyn
in the house tonight!
-Mm-hmm.
-Brooks Allison.
Brooks, what is the song title
we gave you this evening?
-"Stuck in an Elevator with
Ed Sheeran."
[ Laughter ]
-It's very possible.
-Mm-hmm.
-It probably did happen,
you know?
Elevators are kind of an
old technology, but, I mean,
I'm sure that even Ed Sheeran
uses an elevator, yeah.
-Sure.
-And he probably got stuck maybe
once or twice with someone.
And I probably would enjoy being
stuck in an elevator.
But what instrument will you
be playing?
-I'll be playing guitar.
-You'll be playing guitar?
Okay.
Why don't you get over there.
-Thank you.
-Get in the zone.
Come over here, Marcia.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was great, by the way.
-Thank you.
-Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"Stuck in an Elevator with
Ed Sheeran" by Brooks Allison!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I got in an elevator and was
headed for the sixth floor ♪
♪ There was a big crash,
and the elevator works no more ♪
[ Imitates crash ]
♪ I started to panic,
turned around,
there was a red-headed man ♪
♪ Little did I know that I
was stuck in an elevator with ♪
♪ Ed Sheeran ♪
♪ He told me I
looked perfect tonight ♪
♪ I said, "Now's not the time" ♪
♪ He said,
"No, that's just a line
from one of my songs called
'Perfect'" ♪
♪ I said,
"Yeah, I know the song ♪
♪ I hear it all the time ♪
♪ Especially while driving ♪
♪ But right now, all I care
about is surviving this
elevator thing ♪
♪ He said,
"Yeah, that was dumb" ♪
♪ I said,
"Don't worry about it" ♪
♪ And the doors opened up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
Give it up for Brooks Allison
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was awesome.
Brooks, come on over.
♪♪
Thank you, Brooks.
Wow!
It seemed like
it really happened, almost.
Alright, now it's time
to see who won,
so we're going to let our great
audience decide the winner.
Was it Marcia Belsky?
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Brooks Allison?
It looks like the winner is
Brooks Allison!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
Brooks, you're going to be going
home with $1,000
and a "Tonight Show" notebook
for writing more songs.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
-Congratulations.
That was a great job.
-Thank you, thank you.
-But no one goes home
empty-handed.
Our other contestant tonight
will also receive
a notebook and $1,000.
-Ooh!
-Thank you for being here.
Give it up for your
two new instant songwriters.
[ Cheers and applause ]